[Music]
so my name's grant Imran I'm a developer
platform engineer Google cloud platform
previously I allowed open source for D
Suite a P is and in the particular I
love node github and I play the alto sax
in my spare time so the proposed agenda
for today is first what is functions as
a service what is the difference between
functions and micro services writing
google type functions and then this new
thing the functions framework you might
have heard of it
it's an open source platform that powers
Google Cloud functions per note and then
a couple of quick demos so first when
you're thinking about serverless
like we're talking about Google Cloud
functions and being able to develop
functions on the plot so what is
functions as a service also functions as
a service is on managed infrastructure
for executing your code as Kevin said
it's where you can just slowly focus on
your application rather than having to
worry about the infrastructure that
powers it so traditionally you have
servers where you have to maintain your
hardware you have maintenance spare
parts you have staff DevOps have server
rooms you have to worry about you have
tricity cooling and you might have some
idle time these servers and you might
have to pop patch your servers and patch
your hardware and you also have to over
provision if you have traffic spikes in
case it's black friday or or you need to
make sure that your load is kept and so
this can cost a lot of money and cost a
lot of time it's something that you
don't want to do well so why do we
really think about servers and why can't
we just focus on our core application
what we're good at
why can't we let Google do the hard part
well so that's where our functions at
the service comes in so it's part of the
server list movement and it's where your
logic is written by the application
all prayer runs in a managed stateless
computing container and you have special
triggers like HTTP pub sub topics or
Google Cloud Storage upload that is able
to trigger your function it's ephemeral
so that means your function invocation
it won't have global state and it's also
managed by a third party
so serverless Google Cloud functions
it's a serverless environment to build
and connect services with care basically
a function is emitted an event is
emitted a function is triggered and your
code is executed you can trigger a
should be functions from all sorts of
environments also from Drive calendar
Gmail and and maps or you can have your
background functions triggered from
Google Cloud Storage sax driver cloud
pub/sub firebase etc fourth is that it's
managed so your cloud function might be
running in one of Google's data centers
one of these racks you don't really need
to worry about where it's being run so
deep capita stated that google cloud
functions is really useful for the new
york times so Google cloud service
platforms allows us to focus on building
products features without having to
worry about provisioning scaling and
configuration management for the
underlying infrastructure the tools and
abstractions have been a game changer
allowing teams to iterate and scale with
the ease now on to what's the difference
between monoliths and micro services
well so traditionally with a monolith
you have a single application it's one
giant app you deploy all at once and
fundamentally there's different pieces
of logic you might have a couple
databases a couple application pieces of
logic and the idea of micro services is
to really break away this monolithic
application and configure
your points of entry which might be
anything from through cloud surge
uploads HP triggers pops up events and
be able to trigger these independently
so writing functions and Google Cloud
functions also for writing functions you
can specify a request URL which might be
something like this and provide a body
so you can just provide Jason which can
be grant and then the response you'll
just get 200 okay and maybe you'll get a
response body of hello grant cloud
function supports these runtimes so node
6 8 and 10 python 3 7 go 111 and 112
alpha as well as Java 8 behind the
scenes we have an HTP server endpoint we
provide a fully qualified domain and
that's a self certificate auto-scaling
as your users hit your function more
often and we also integrate with Specter
ever logging and stack driver error
reporting you can deploy from the cloud
console UI or from the command line on
two languages and the CLI also bring
note i click google cloud function will
look something like this it's your
typical node where you can export a
variable this is just hello world and
we're powering this 3 Express 4 and she
can simply just read stops s200 and send
the message python it's pretty similar
it uses flask and you can post the args
if you want and just return a string
hello world and forego we use the native
I used to be client and you can send
your response right natively and go
you can deploy Google cloud functions
from the CLI and do everything from
calling functions listing all your
functions deploying deleting and listing
all the event types there's some
advanced options for the CLI that allows
you to specify different runtimes
different memory allocations up to two
gigabytes a number of retries in case
your function fails you can also specify
that this function will run as a certain
service scale timeouts environment
variables triggers etc and you can learn
more at cloud.google.com slash functions
now I'm really excited to talk about
this part this is something that I've
been working on with Slovak and the
Google cloud functions team this is the
front functions framework so what is the
functions framework well it's really a
new underlying backbone for Google Cloud
functions it's an open source project
it's under github.com slash Google cloud
platform flash functions framework and
it enables for local development of your
code if you're wishing to not spend 30
or 60 seconds to wait for your functions
to deploy you can simply locally install
the functions framework and have the
same environment that's used with Google
Cloud functions for at least four node
10 right now and we also provide a
transparent December and so you can pin
your function framework on a specific
version so that you know that your
function is going to run in the same
environment even if you g-cloud
functions pushkin inside the functions
framework what does it do well so it
does a light transformation of your code
first loads the court the source code it
creates a light HTTP server in this case
Express for burn it and it creates a
route for your equip request there's a
preset docker file you can see on the
github repo and we spin up container
instances in response to increased
demand
cool now I have a couple demos that I
would love to show you so first here we
have our Google cloud platform projects
where I have deployed a function called
BTC simple way to invoke a function is
just T called the URL and here I
actually have a function deployed that's
calling the coinbase API and getting
that current Bitcoin price at a certain
date so this is in 2017 you could buy a
single Bitcoin for $2,100
C in 2019 it's increased to fifty four
hundred let's go try to run this locally
though so with a new functions framework
we can simply start the functions
framework and so this is using the local
NPM package and just serving a local
local host you're all and I have the
query parameter set up here and it's
really exactly the same same good so you
can see in 2016
etc
and price changes we can also instead of
powering our functions locally let's say
we want to go and test against our
deployed version also rather than having
to go to Chrome maybe what we want to do
is from the terminal we can just use
g-cloud and call the function and it'll
execute and provide the data right then
in there let's say you have a Google
sheet and you want to use Google Cloud
functions to power some of the data
processing well I think Google sheets is
a very flexible UI and it's really
powerful
when you can combine a Google Cloud
functions and Google sheets so here i've
created a custom function called bt sees
CF it takes in a date and you can simply
press enter and this will call a cloud
function which should we just deploy it
and it'll return the exact body response
from that so the powerful part about
Google sheets is that you can simply
just drag and drop or or click the
bottom right corner and you can see
there's all these prices for all these
dates and it's powered by Google cloud
functions so how does this work might
ask well so we can go to tools and then
script editor where you have some
lightweight Apps Script code basically
we provide the date in this format and
then we do a URL fetch which is just a
fetch to this cloud endpoint and then we
parse the JSON and we just want the
amount and so we just return that so
that's really cool let's see
man so those are three different ways in
which you can call your club function
from the command line from a browser and
from Google sheets
so in summary we showed what functions
as a services functions versus
microservices writing doodles live
functions that open source function
framework and demo of three ways in
which you can call cloud functions you
can learn more about the functions
framework at get io / DCF - functions
framework at that thank you so much my
name is grant Timmerman I would love if
you have any questions to tweeted me at
Graham Timmerman thank you
[Music]